hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even
more
there was looters that came out of Gaza
who were not part of
Hamas my simple
question my simple question is this was
it a terror attack anyone who killed
civilians yeah should be condemned a
terror reprehensible anyone who kills C
is a criminal was it a terror attack
what October the 7th and we know asked
you you said what define the terror
attack is that they you target C from
yes okay you target civilians right so
then I I want to ask I answer that
question I want to ask that question but
I just just for the sake of consistency
when the British army targeted German
civilians in World War II was that a
terror attack no because they were
responding to Nazi Germany's attempt to
destroy the world wait a minute rewind
that rewind that wait a minute wait this
is this this is the bit this is the bit
this is the bit bro this is a strong
very strong ending this the bit where
you say what job says hold on hold on
yeah hold on wait hold on listen to it
listen to this very carefully what
define the Terr attack is that you
target you from yes okay you target
civilians right so then I I want to ask
I answer that question I want to ask
that question but I just just just
answer my question targeted German
civilians in World War II was that a
terror attack no because they were
responding to Nazi Germany's attempt to
destroy the world so you're saying that
say so you're saying that uh because of
who they were fighting it's not a terror
attack to kill to Target civilians is
that is that what you're saying have to
WRA this up
I'm a go back go back go go back
go his neighbors are calling the police
right let's see that again let's see
that again let's see that again it's not
a terror attack to kill to Target
civilians is that what you're saying we
have to wrap this up
I'm I'm saying there's no moral
equivalence between us defending
ourselves against Nazi Germany who
committed a holocaust that killed in
fact they killed 12 million people did
Britain launch war on Germany because
the Jews huh did Britain declare war on
Germany because for the sake of Jews
Britain declar war on did wi Churchill
in his ultimatum H did he say stop
persecuting Jews do you know why because
at that time anti-Semitism was so Rife
that people didn't care about the plight
of the Jews it was only afterwards after
they discovered the death camps and so
on so forth don't pretend that the
Allies launched this war for the sake of
of Jews antism anti-Semitism only
discover the horror of the concentration
camps towards the end of the war we did
to save our democracy and freedom and
the guess Palestinians are doing what
are the pal doing the pales are idea
with any moral equivalence is ridiculous
but let me come back one more time
before we finish to my simple question
was what happened on October the 7th a
terror attack I'm I'm and I'm telling
you that if you refuse to call the the
bombing the bombing of B of has a terror
attack then why leave it there is that
not hypocritical I'm totally trying to
call it a terror attack willing to call
it a terror attack too let's let's join
each other in condemning both including
the IDF as what they're doing as as a
terror ATT believe that's being hpoc
that's being
hypocritical this is a terror attack you
have to be consist
final you know yesterday I
was that was very strong of diomatic and
political issues this
is I think
your brothers and sisters in Islam net
from Norway are establishing a mid a DA
Center this Center this Masid this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam so
give generously and Allah will give you
even
more